the Republicans attitude in Congress has
been take the money we gave you for
Ebola and use it to fight Zika they're
thinking being you know the Ebola
epidemic ended quicker than we expected
and so there must be money left over you
know the truth is public health funding
and and money for fighting epidemics is
woefully underfunded in this country and
so a lot of the Ebola money went into
creating things in in Africa that are
needed to fight diseases that future
diseases that might come here I mean we
don't want Lassa fever coming here we
don't want Congo Crimean hemorrhagic
fever coming here where there's a lot of
diseases in Africa we don't want coming
here so a lot of that money went to set
up laboratory capacity to set up
surveillance networks to do things that
are extremely useful for protecting the
United States so some of that money was
spent and some of it was committed
yeah the CDC and and the HHS took some
money from that budget they took some
money now they're taking it from other
budgets eventually if the disease keeps
spreading
they're gonna have to come up with new
money to fight it and right now the
disease is still spreading I don't
expect it to be limited to to one square
mile of Miami I think before this hot
wet summer is over we're gonna see a lot
more Zika in this country so I think
it's probably gonna take more money but
like I said I'm a science reporter not a
local reporter so I don't have the bunch
of documents in front of me I'm just
using
81 million dollars transferred over to
biomedical research the story last week
in the New York Times adding that
lawmakers feuded for months how the
money should be marked and spent
Democrats blocked a consideration of a
Republican measure that would have
allocated 1.1 billion of ID Zika but
included provisions that would have
banned funding for Planned Parenthood
the house minority Speaker Nancy Pelosi
at a conference press conference last
week talked about the Zika money for
Zika and research adding her concerns as
far as a budget or at least more money
as concerned here's part of what you had
to say what is it with them that they
don't understand sexually transmitted
disease you use contraception you know I
grant them their position on many issues
we have a different philosophy but come
on come back do the job do the job
and when I anytime I see one of our
Republican colleagues I'm in asking what
was it that you accomplished during your
break that was more important than the
health and the well-being and the safety
and the security of the American people
let's go to keyboard New Jersey pat on
our Republican line you're on with our
guests go ahead hi thank you I'd like to
know given that fact to be human to
human transmission I realize it's still
early in the presence of Zika in the US
but do you know how long someone can
transmit the disease once they're
infected and given that how safe is our
blood supply going to be going into the
future thank you
not everybody who gets Zika is capable
of sexually transmitted it it's been a
surprise to learn that some viruses can
get into the testicles basically and and
and set up an infection there but that's
not universally the case so only some
men who get Zika get infections so
thorough that it gets into them deeply
enough into their immunological
privileged area so they can pass on the
disease originally they had found it
only for about two months in semen now
they found it for about six months but
what they found is is viral RNA it's not
clearly live virus so this is still kind
of an open question for scientists the
CDC's attitude so far has been look we
found what we're pretty sure is live
virus for two months so let's act out of
an abundance of caution and say that
people shouldn't have unprotected sex if
the woman is thinking of getting
pregnant for six months they sort of
take the known danger period and they
triple it
so that right now that's that's the
advice it basically that any woman who's
pregnant should avoid unprotected sex
with a man who's had as he get infection
for the length of the pregnancy because
a man can have a Zika infection without
any symptoms although it's not it's also
clear that people get Zika and are not
able to transmit it sexually but it's
very hard to test somebody they're gonna
run tests on on everybody can't really
run tests on everybody's having sex with
pregnant women and it's
too much testing to do on the blood
supply there are tests for testing on
the blood supply they're not perfect
they're pretty good there you know
there's there's a window period in which
any any blood test isn't it isn't it
will will miss an infection because it
just hasn't multiplied the number of
times in the blood it needs to multiply
to be detectable I think the window
period for this test is about eight days
but I'd have to go back and look it up
but one thing the government does or
rather the blood bank industry does is
in when you know an area has Zika
infection they stop accepting new blood
from that area there's also some kinds
of what's called pathogen and activation
technology that can kill the virus we
don't use that in whole blood but we do
use it in in things like a clotting
factor or hemophiliacs and things like
that so you can render the blood safe
even if it's infected by Zika
it's an unusual technology but it is
used for for clotting factor and things
like that
next up Christine from Alabama my
independent line you're on with our
guests go ahead yes mr. MacNeil I was
listening I heard you're a science
reporter I was wondering if you have a
specific science background also
obviously mosquitoes are the
transmission source of the Zika what is
the actual mutation source of the virus
and how did that originate and is there
vaccine currently in development with a
CDC thank you okay
I'm afraid my science back I have an
undergraduate degree in rhetoric from UC
Berkeley the science I know is basically
self-taught from being a reporter in
science I was a Broadway theater
reporter and then I was in Africa
correspondent and from Africa I segwayed
into into covering aids and from aids
when I came back to New York I started
covering diseases in general and I cover
sort of all the infectious diseases that
might well that hurt people out in the
poor countries of the world and that
also reap might reach in those countries
to this one and Zeek is a pretty good
example of that the second question was
was is there what is the mutation we
don't really know that there's any
important in mutation in Zika that's
made it more dangerous or more transmits
the disease has been known about since
1947 it was in monkeys in Africa in 1947
it was then found to be in humans but by
the 1950s I realize it was and he was
but because it was this mild and very
obscure disease nobody started testing
for it really until about 2007 when it
turned up on Yap Island and the CDC went
out there to investigate an outbreak of
this mystery disease and that's when
they began to really start
characterizing the virus there's no
really obvious mutation in the virus
that makes it makes it more dangerous to
babies or makes it more transmissible
among humans but when you have a
population that's that's totally naive
to a disease it's never had a disease
before and you start transmission you
can get a lot of transmission of that
disease I mean that the classic example
is what happened when white people came
to this country and brought all their
diseases on to the American Indian
population I mean the American Indians
had never had measles had never had
smallpox I've never had tuberculosis
I've never had lots of diseases and 90%
of them were wiped out within a couple
of generations by the diseases that were
introduced we're seeing something like
that with Zika and that we have a
totally naive population in this in in
all of the Americas from here down to
Argentina luckily for us it's a
relatively mild disease except for
babies the question of the vaccine is no
there is no vaccine now the best hope
probably there will be a vaccine this is
unusual it's not like malaria it's not
like AIDS it appears to be something
that we can make a vaccine against
pretty easily because it's related to
yellow fever it's related to dengue and
it's related to Japanese encephalitis
and there are vaccines for those and
they work pretty well but even though
the vaccines are being made and are just
beginning to be tested now it still
takes about two years of testing because
you know with vaccines with cancer drugs
are given to a sick person somebody
who's in danger of dying so you can get
quite experimental with them with a
vaccine you're giving it to a healthy
person and in this case your target is a
woman who either has a baby or is about
to have a baby and so that is the most
vulnerable population so you want to be
absolutely dead sure that your vaccine
is as safe and effective as
it could be before you start handing it
out that testing is expected to take two
years
another thing that's gonna complicate
that is it looks like the epidemic Peaks
and disappears pretty fast Columbia has
already declared as epidemic effectively
over it's not totally over there's still
some cases but it's over as a public
health emergency and so if there isn't
an epidemic around to test the vaccine
in we may never get the final tests on
this vaccine so it's kind of a race
against time but in any case the best
experts say two years minimum before
there's a vaccine so that's not going to
be a very helpful protection while this
disease is is raging mr. McNeil a viewer
off at Twitter asked if you anticipate
athletes returning from the Summer Games
in Rio coming back with symptoms not
know I mean first of all we're not
hearing any reports out of Rio of a lot
of athletes suffering symptoms I was
expecting that I didn't hear it I'll
tell you that I wasn't expect it very
much because this is Rios winter August
is winter down there it doesn't mean
it's cold in Rio you've seen the
pictures there's no snow there's no
snowman around but it's in the 70s
rather than being in the 90s and
mosquito transmission since the peak and
and fall for all diseases dengue
chikungunya stuff like that so there's
relatively low mosquito transmission
also there's been a big epidemic of Zika
in Rio so a lot of the population there
has what's called herd immunity that is
their immune to the virus so the
mosquitoes can't pick it up from them
and give it to the athletes so I I was
unsure what would happen you know all
summer before the game started now the
game too started it doesn't look like
there's a whole lot of transmission it
does not look like a lot of athletes are
suffering from Zika so I don't expect
any big transfer of it back to this
country or any other country Donnell
McNeal our guest talked about the Zika
virus the author of a book on it Zika
the emerging epidemic reports on science
and health for the New York Times let's
hear from Martha from Connecticut
Democrats line you're on with our guest
go ahead hi I just like to know that
question was asked and answered if you
are scientist
and you said it know that you had no
background in that but reporting you
have excellent background so my question
is this how how would we in Connecticut
being the distance that you stated that
it takes for them to fly or to travel
how would they get to the states with
this disease basically being a South
American disease how did it come here in
the first place was there stagnant water
on the air so then it just ends
no no it's very humid gotcha kala thanks
mr. McNeil it's it's people it's not
mosquitoes a lot of diseases go around
the world either in the noses of people
or in the Bloods in the blood of people
you can get on a plane in southern China
and be in the United States in less than
a day and if you have a particularly bad
flu you can transmit it to the next
person you say you can transmit it on
the airplane with remember this is a
mosquito-borne disease but it's also a
blood-borne disease so you get infected
in in Brazil or in Puerto Rico or in the
Dominican Republic or in you know
virtually anywhere and and then you fly
to this country and if you're in the
right place well one you can sexually
transmitted it to your partner and two
if the right mosquitoes are in place
they can pick it up from you and
transfer to other people it's not
instant the mosquito the the you know
mosquito female mosquitoes suck blood
into their into their mid guts their
abdomens and then it takes about a week
or so for the virus to get from the
mosquitoes gut to its salivary glands
and be able to transmit it on but you
have to remember there are three to
three thousand different kinds of
mosquitoes in the world only a few
species and only one species it's common
in the United States that we know about
transmits this virus there's a second
one a t-table pictus that also
transmitted it's not very well those
mosquitoes ATS a gypsy are almost never
in Connecticut in a super hot super wet
summer like this one is shaping up to be
if you're in New York City right now
there's a possibility of some 80s and
jedis mosquitoes turning up in
Connecticut late you know in
August or September but it's not a big
risk I mean the real risk is in is in
Florida Alabama and Mississippi Houston
and it's also mostly in cities because
you have to have a kind of spin up where
the mosquitoes bite a lot of people
transfer a lot of virus to a lot of
people and then more mosquitoes get
infected and you get a sort of whirlwind
of a virus going on when people live
outside of cities you don't normally get
outbreaks of these kinds of
mosquito-borne diseases it's why yellow
fever for example is mostly a forest
disease although they're having some
giant outbreaks in some cities in Africa
right now in Luanda Angola and Kinshasa
in Democratic Republic of Congo from
Ohio independent line parikh good
morning what Salameh hello my name is
tarek mama thanks for taking my call I'm
Indian Pakistani and general
practitioner while that I live in Ohio I
most from mainly as a Pakistan just a
couple of years ago and then I came to
the u.s. in 2005 on because of the
extremists the people like the kid naic
and he was an Isis recruiter actually so
I came here and I faced the the virus
Zika which is very dangerous it's a I
just want to let people know that it's a
mosquito-borne infection which was first
identified in Africa in 1947 it has
spread significantly across the world
since the first reported case in Brazil
in 2015 for most people is a very mild
infection and isn't harmful however
scientists believe it's behind an
unprecedented rise in the number of
children being born with unusually and
they have small heads in zika-infected
areas
gotcha we got we got it we already got
that from our guest this morning
actually what would you like to ask him
specifically what is the best way to
educate people on occasions that they
get this disease and they you know catch
it because I think education is weren't
the most important things these days for
people to actually know what our bias is
like Zika thank you gotcha
thank you like i'm salaam sorry I didn't
quite understand the question was it
what is the best way to treat people he
was asking about education of people
what's the best way to
educate people oh you know posters TV
ads radio ads you have to reach people
through every medium there is you know
in New York City they had posters up in
the subways in April about you know the
education has to be pointed towards
towards the risk and in New York City
they had these posters up in the subways
in April and May talking about the
mosquitoes and I remember sort of
looking at the posters and thinking with
these pictures of giant mosquitoes on
them and thinking it's really cold and
windy out there there are no no
dangerous mosquitoes around right now
and they're not likely to arrive in
August at the same time there are people
coming back from Puerto Rico and the
American Republic and other countries in
South America with this disease there
really ought to be pictures of
good-looking guys on these posters
rather than mosquitoes because they are
right now the only transmission risk so
you have to think about the you know the
risk that you're facing and then you
have to give people fairly detailed
information in a way that they can
understand but it's not too scary for
them people need to understand that this
is not you know this is not the Doomsday
virus this is not you know the the giant
threat this is a very serious threat to
unborn children but for everybody else
it's not a very serious threat and so
there shouldn't be any panic about this
but there should be extreme care that
women who are pregnant or or thinking of
getting pregnant stay away from these
areas or think about not being pregnant
during that time if they have to be in
that area because it's a it's a real
risk and you know the chances of getting
it are small but the downside is
absolutely terrible and that's something
that you know city health authorities
public health authorities and anybody
else who's in you know and their
business communicating with the public
needs to it's been do let's hear from
Robert in Indiana Republican line
good morning good morning how are you
well thanks go ahead okay you talked
about funding for this Nica virus why
don't we take it from Paree player and
pad parent plant or whatever they call
it these abortions because we're killing
our children for no good reason
Tony will be up next Tony's in Fontana
California Republican line hey how you
doing this morning I was expected no hi
disease from 1947 because of epidemic in
2015 where's the transmissions a factor
as to where it's all of a sudden this
big issue like when I was a little kid I
got bit by 20 mosquitoes I never had to
worry about Lika and now 2016 it's all
of a sudden you gotta watch the
mosquitoes so can you explain it please
sure can I ask where you were bitten by
mosquitoes as a kid oh he's already left
us sorry about that oh all right I mean
there there was a time when getting
bitten by mosquitoes in this country
could could lead you to have malaria and
and some other dangerous diseases
the answer is diseases change over time
I don't mean the disease changes up and
the transmission changes the disease was
discovered in 1947 in Africa it probably
had transmitted there for thousands of
years and never came to this country
unlike yellow fever and some other
diseases that did not come to this
country with the slave trade which some
which some diseases like yellow fever
did it it went at some point from Africa
to Asia it circulated there because it's
a mild disease nobody really paid
attention to it you also have to
understand it's really tough to test
your diseases when you don't know what
they are it's fairly easy to do a test
when you know what it is because you've
designed the test book when somebody
just has a mild fever and a rash unless
you have a specific test for that thing
you don't you don't know what it is it
took them five years to do the research
to realize that the virus that was in
the monkey and in in Africa in 1947 was
not yellow fever was not bengay was not
boonie Ameri fever was not a leafy
forest fever was not same leaky forestry
if there are lots and lots of diseases
out there that most people are happy
they don't know the names of this
happens to be one that's traveled the
world it went to Asia
nobody developed a test for it and
because it was mild nobody noticed it it
was in places where you had epidemics of
malaria you had epidemics of dengue you
had epidemics of yellow fever
you had other much more serious diseases
so nobody really notices one it's
circulated under the radar it was in
Micronesia and Yap Islands those are
islands at the United States and the
Japanese fought over during World War
two
it created an epidemic there but it was
mild it was thought to be unimportant
but more work was done and a test was
created because the CDC went to
investigate that epidemic because we've
had a relationship ever since World War
two were those Islands then it got to
French Polynesia infected 66% of the
islands within seven months that's where
they discovered that there was a
connection to Gyan beret the kind of
paralysis they have a bunch of people
who ended up hospitalized with paralysis
there and but they did not make the
connection to microcephaly to the damage
to the babies because it doesn't damage
every baby it's a damages the minority
of them and then finally when it came to
Brazil you had a situation where you had
millions of cases because you had people
very crowded together in the slums so
you have you have to have all these
factors you have to have you have to
have jet travel in order for people with
the virus and their blood to get quickly
enough from place to place to transmit
the disease you have to have populations
crowded in urban slums which you have in
in Brazil but you didn't have in Brazil
50 years ago and you also have to have
people who tend to give birth in
hospitals because that's when you notice
something like microcephaly there might
have only been you know five cases of
microcephaly in a hospital but they knew
that was unusual because normally
doctors in those Brazilian hospitals
were only seeing maybe one case of
microcephaly every two three years and
suddenly they have five in one hospital
seven in another hospital and they
realize kind of something serious is
going on here so it's possible for there
are diseases under the radar that we
don't know about right now that we will
hear about in the next few years and
that's the kind of thing that keeps me
employed is that new diseases are always
popping out Charlie from Paducah
Kentucky independent line
yeah thanks c-span for contributing to
public discourse appreciate your efforts
my question is what do the Bill and
Melinda Gates Foundation what do they
know about mosquitoes and can they help
with this problem Bill & Melinda Gates
Foundation has a lot of people who are
experts in mosquitoes they're not I mean
they're playing some role in Zika it
takes them a while to ramp up I know
they gave money to do Puerto Rico for
example to help get the message out that
the people needed to take their disease
seriously and take precautions against
it because Puerto Rico is so broke that
they had no money even from public
service ads or you know TV TV spots or
newspaper ads you know their mosquito I
haven't looked specifically into this so
I shouldn't try to answer the question
with that without digging into it but
yeah they have mosquito experts who can
give who are normally experts in in
malaria dengue and other diseases who
can be helpful and they are giving money
right now most of the budget for other
countries is coming from those countries
own mosquito fighting efforts I mean you
don't have to give a lot of money to
Brazil the Colombia or the countries
they they have mosquito diseases all the
time they need to fight them in the
United States you know a lot of that
money has come from the state of Florida
you don't normally go to because they're
fighting mosquitoes all the time they
don't normally go to the Foundation's
to to ask for money you usually since
the taxpayers are a risk you ask the
taxpayers to pay for for you know their
own protection so I I wouldn't count on
this as something that that the Gates
Foundation has to do it's you know
fighting Ebola in in Africa when it was
coming to this country was something
that every American should take an
interest in it shouldn't have to run to
the foundation's every time you want
money you ought to be able to tell
people look this is in your own
self-interest this is protecting your
own babies pony up those taxes now and
make sure that the you know that your
own family is protected the book is iike
the emerging epidemic written by our
guest who reports for the New York Times
as well Donald McNeal
joining us Amy from Richmond Virginia
Democrats line your next yeah Kyle
thanks for c-span and I'm really glad
that you're having this program on this
morning because I do feel that people
really have lack of education about this
disease and about mosquitoes but anyway
I came in late on the show and I don't
know if you talk to you at about how to
the best way to eliminate mosquitoes
from someone's yard because it seems
like sometimes people you know panic and
they spray all these pesticides and
everything and I think sometimes people
don't realize that you can have overkill
on pesticides when they were having all
this outbreak in Brazil and I saw the
men on TV just human dating all over the
place you know I can understand the fear
of pregnant women getting the disease
that I kept thinking well you know this
stuff that they're spraying all over
everywhere could be just as bad for the
baby and one baby you know as the
celeritas and so I wish you could speak
a little bit about the best place to
eliminate mosquitoes around your yard
and the fact that generally mosquitoes
once they're born they don't fly you
know 50 miles and search of somebody's
butt they tend to stay in a you know a
smallish sort of area so I was loving it
people speak about that thanks caller
okay I really don't agree that there is
any equality between the risk from
pesticides and the risk from this virus
I mean we know this virus destroys
babies its pesticides you know people
have any irrational fear of pesticides
in this case and first of all pesticides
aren't the whole answer they you know
the way to eliminate we're talking about
one mosquito here the 80s a tip time
mosquito that's that's the main
transmitter the way it's a mosquito that
loves to bite humans it doesn't run off
and bite birds or deers or horses or
other things away so mosquitoes do it
likes to live in human gardens it likes
to lay its eggs in relatively clean
water like in a birdbath
like in a swimming pool that isn't
chlorinated like in your rain gutters if
they've got rain standing in them like
in your bets water dish if it isn't
cleaned regularly I mean that's the kind
of places a Tuesday they will get inside
your house and lay eggs in your shower
drain if it's not if it's not flush
flush with water regularly so it's a
mosquito that likes to live in very
close proximity to humans it tends to
breed in human gardens in the human
houses and it will fly into your house
and hide under your bed or hide in in
your closet until it's quite enough and
safer to come out and bite so it's a you
know you know the CDC refers to it as a
cockroach of mosquitoes because it likes
to hang around humans and it likes
behind in dark places it's very
different from the mosquitoes that
transmit West Nile virus or some of the
others so look that the risk from
pesticides pesticides are dangerous if
you inhale them in large amounts if
you're an agricultural worker and you're
and you're getting them on your hands or
breathing large clouds of them but you
know the occasional truck passing
through or the a plate occasional plane
going over with the occasional fog in
your garden is does not pose a serious
risk to your unborn child it's like you
know there's an irrational fear of deep
and other other chemicals in this
country it's it's bad science it's it's
it's fear of it's fear of something that
is not really that dangerous and this
virus is extremely dangerous and many
more babies will be kept safe and will
survive if this mosquito is beaten then
if we ignore the mosquito because of an
irrational fear of pesticides Pat up
next from Coatesville Pennsylvania
Democrats line go ahead good morning I
just have to say that I've heard several
different discussions about just exactly
where babies are being affected and I
understand that it's a very limited
space that it's in northern Brazil and
French Polynesia am I wrong in that are
there babies being born in say Puerto
Rico with microcephaly I understand that
they think it might be a combination in
the areas where microcephaly is as a
come out break that um that there is
concern that there's combination of
other viruses like people that have
already had death the dengue virus
or some kind of agricultural chemicals
in combination because is it true that
the microcephaly is has been local to
only two locations or our babies having
microcephaly in other areas thank you
the the epidemic in French Polynesia
began and ended in 2000 began in 2013
and ended in 2014 and there hasn't been
a case there since there were 18 cases
of confirmed or suspected microcephaly
there brazil has had more than 1,700
cases of microcephaly but there's
britain microcephaly in colombia Cape
Verde Islands Panama think in Mexico
definitely been a bunch of cases in the
United States that is done yes there's
been microcephaly in Puerto Rico there
have been a number of babies born with
microcephaly in the United States
although its mothers who picked it up in
other countries and had the babies here
there have been babies born with
microcephaly even in Slovenia in Europe
that was a travel related case and in
some other in some other countries there
was some suspicion that it was necessary
to be but that there might be what's
called antibody-mediated any party
dependent enhancement which is which is
creates that having had dengue fever
before would make it more likely that
you would get a serious case of Zika or
or microcephaly and a baby that hasn't
been proven it seems possible that a
woman can just get Zika virus and have
severe damage to her to her baby this we
should still going on that on that but
that's the jury is still out but it it
looks as if Zika alone can cause the
condition sorry I forgot one one part of
the question but it's okay because we
have oh sorry was it was about two
agricultural chemicals the agricultural
chemicals have nothing to do with it
most of the most of this disease struck
people who live in in urban areas often
in the in the large slums and
with their they live where there are no
agricultural chemicals at all it did my
particular strike farm workers as there
that that was a absolute red herring
it's a false rumor let's take one more
call and this will be from a lane in
Florida Republican line hello Elaine
you're on go ahead hi I just wanted to
tell you first of all that I'm 77 years
old I'm not having any more babies I'm
not having any more sex and I have lived
in Florida for 14 years I have never
seen a mosquito
I've never gotten bit by a mosquito in
Florida so one of my chances of getting
a the virus where do you live in Florida
that you have never seen a mosquito your
chances of get it would depend a lot on
where you live in Florida and and
whether there's local transmission
congratulations I guess I'm being safe
from sexual transmission but the
mosquito transmission in southern
Florida right now is a risk I mean right
now it's confined to one neighborhood of
Miami but that doesn't necessarily mean
that it won't spread later in the year
we're waiting to see what happens and if
you can avoid all mosquito bites in
Florida you're doing a great job of
personal Public Health a lot of other
people are at risk and and so it remains
dangerous for for pregnant women in
Florida or remains potentially dangerous
for pregnant women in Florida for the
rest of this season
the book is Zika the emerging epidemic
written by our guest Donald McNeil of
the New York Times mr. MacNeil thanks
for your time this morning
thank you very much for inviting me
campaign 2016 will be the topic of our
discussion with our next guest Reid
Wilson of the hill and then later on in
the program and are your money segment
we are going to take a look at NASA's
Juno probe to Jupiter hopefully we'll
send back detailed images of the planet
a billion dollar price tag for this
project Donal our James green from NASA
the planetary science director will join
us to talk about that project later in
the program Washington journal continues
after this
[Music]
at c-span org you can watch our public
affairs and political programming any
time at your convenience on your desktop
laptop or mobile device here's how go to
our homepage c-span org and click on the
video library search bar here you can
type in the name of a speaker the
sponsor of a bill or even the event
topic review the list of search results
and click on the program you'd like to
watch or refine your search with our
many search tools if you're looking for
our most current programs and you don't
want to search the video library our
home page as many current programs ready
for your immediate viewing such as
today's Washington journal or the events
we covered that day c-span org is a
public service of your cable or
satellite provider so if you're a c-span
watcher check it out at c-span org
the c-span radio app makes it easy to
continue to follow the 2016 election
wherever you are it's free to download
from the Apple App Store or Google Play
get audio coverage and up-to-the-minute
schedule information for c-span radio
and c-span television plus podcast times
for our popular public affairs book and
history programs stay up to date on all
the election coverage c-span's radio app
means you always have c-span on the go
jinkin journal continues joining us now
Reid Wilson with the hill he's their
national correspondent covering aspects
of campaign 2016 good morning hey Peter
are there new battleground states
emerging this cycle that we've seen in
years past
so the Clinton campaign isn't calling
them battleground states they're calling
them expansion the state states they
think they can go beyond the traditional
battleground map and even if they don't
win they'll at least force Republicans
to play a little defense last week in
Chicago senior Clinton official was
talking to a bunch of Democratic state
legislators they let me in the room for
some reason and she was she mentioned a
couple of states in particular Arizona
and Georgia are the two where the
Clinton campaign has started to invest
staff you know nobody no Democrat has
seriously competed there since Bill
Clinton who won when what Georgia in 92
and and Arizona in 96 and that was
because Ross Perot is on the ballot now
you've got a very different type of
candidate who's on the ballot and so the
Clinton campaign thinks they can expand
into those two states they've hired
senior staff in both places they're
starting to open offices one of the
things that they're paying a lot of
attention to is the fact that both of
those states have competitive US Senate
races not as competitive in Georgia but
in Arizona at least Senator John McCain
faces a pretty tough reelection fight
and he faces a he himself believes it's
going to be a tough reelection fight if
Donald Trump ends up sort of an
albatross around Republican necks across
the country Democrats think that if they
can make it competitive in the in the
race for the White House they can sort
of pull representative Ann Kirkpatrick
along with them as far as these emerging
states or even in battleground states
what's the the
we like on the ground there for both
Canada Clinton and Donald Trump yeah so
the Clinton machine is only beginning to
be formed these are states where
Democrats have not competed very well at
the statewide level I'm struggling to
think of the last Democrat who won
statewide in Arizona but it was probably
governor Janet Napolitano when she won
reelection in in 96
I'm sorry 2006 uh in in Georgia it's
been a very long time so the the sort of
the democratic party structure has sort
of atrophied in a lot of these states
what the Clinton campaign hopes to do is
to build a real organization that can
either win now or force Republicans to
spend in some of these states and every
dollar you spend in Arizona is a dollar
you're not spending in Ohio and possibly
set up Democrats for success in the long
run the clomp the Trump campaign
structure is is non-existent in a lot of
these states in a lot of battleground
states as well the Trump campaign is not
built like a traditional campaign
whether that's a good thing or a bad
thing I mean we'll find out in November
but the fact is there's not much of a
Trump campaign in any of these states
the Republican National Committee has
opened offices around the country and
they're a lot more organized and
involved and they've got staffers in a
lot of these key states but for the most
part somebody like John McCain running
for re-election he's gonna have to rely
on his own campaign in his own state
party which has its own troubles whereas
an Kirkpatrick the likely the Democratic
nominee for that seat is now gonna get a
lot of help from the Clintons and from
the Democratic National Committee
national correspondent Reid Wilson
joining us from the hill to talk about
campaign 2016 if you want to address
questions to him here's how you can do
so 202 sep for eighty eight thousand one
for Republicans 202 seven four eight
8,000 for Democrats
202 separate eight thousand two for
independents Reid Wilson a lot of talk
about the current status of relationship
between the RNC and key Republicans and
Donald Trump do you see a parting of the
ways at all does experience tell us this
or at least history tell us this I am
struggling to find a moment in history
that's it is like this
it's it's a tough to figure it out but
whether or not the Trump campaign and
the RNC are seeing things eye-to-eye the
Republican National Committee plays a
huge role in terms of electing all these
other Republicans they will have dozens
of field staffers in Ohio and in Florida
and in North Carolina and in all the the
battleground states the happy confluence
for them and for us as reporters is that
all of the key Senate battlegrounds and
most of the key house battlegrounds to
are also White House states so you've
got the seven states that President
Obama won twice where Republican
senators are up for re-election or
seeking re-election
I mentioned Ohio Rob Portman is running
for reelection there Florida Marco Rubio
is running for reelection North Carolina
Senator Richard burr so even if the RNC
isn't obviously pulling out staff or
even if they're not fully committed to
Donald Trump they're gonna have staffers
on the ground in places where
Republicans need staffers come November
and then even it said today Hillary
Clinton will be in Pennsylvania Donald
Trump will be in Ohio two battleground
states the topic foreign policy and I
mean this is sort of the the
battleground that Donald Trump exposes
is the sort of white working-class
voters especially in Rust Belt states he
has said he's gonna make a big play for
Pennsylvania he said he's going to make
a big play for Ohio Michigan you know
these sort of that if Donald Trump has
reignited a discussion on trade and and
NAFTA and CAFTA these are the states
where things like that are going to take
place where that discussion and debate
are gonna take place those are states
that have been hit hardest by trade
deals which while the trade deals may
have been good for America as a whole
they still hurt some people and though
some people live in Pennsylvania Ohio
Michigan Indiana places that are going
to be on the battleground map this year
again if you want to see those events
for those two candidates go to c-span
org for more information on that senator
Secretary of State Clinton's speech will
be at 12:45 this afternoon Donald Trump
at two o'clock this afternoon and c-span
org as we
can see that and learn more information
about that as well and even as we talk
about all that even in the papers today
the Washington Times says that
Connecticut now is somehow an interest
for Trump and calling it a it's an
unusual move it is Donald Trump has he's
fascinating in this is like if you ask
him and so I was let me back up a little
bit talking to this this senior Clinton
campaign person the political director
Amanda Renteria last week I asked her
about Utah we've we've had a lot of
there's been a lot of talk that Utah
might be on the table because Donald
Trump isn't playing there terribly well
and so I asked her about it you know is
Utah real and she said you know what's
really hard and that's sort of the
political way of saying we're not gonna
win Utah and I don't think the first of
all the Clinton campaign doesn't need to
win you type you win Utah you're talking
about a you know 500 electoral vote
landslide on the other hand you ask
Donald Trump whether or not he's going
to do well in the state and there's not
that sort of same you know politic
answer like we're you know it's gonna be
hard meaning we're not gonna win he
talks about he's asked about Connecticut
yeah sure we'll win there in New York
you know his home state of New York is
hired apparently a separate pollster to
take a look at New York and you know the
Republican Party is not gonna win New
York State on a on a presidential level
if they do it's gonna be a 500 electoral
vote swing the other way he's talked
about Oregon he's talked about
Washington State these are two states
that are the most liberal in the country
in a lot of senses that haven't been on
the battleground for a long time so the
Trump campaign I mean there's a reason
that Republican candidates go to
Connecticut it's not to hold rallies
it's to raise money I don't know if
Donald Trump is doing that today let's
hear from viewers this is Robert in
Henderson Kentucky independent line go
ahead good morning good morning hosting
good morning mr. Reid sir I'm an
independent
my family is long been Democrat I was
born in Los Angeles Kentucky
I don't like Mitch McConnell I think
he's very disrespectful and unfair no my
question to you sir is these and Donald
Trump has any interest in actually
receiving black votes because he doesn't
seem
I want to address any black issues or
come to any black media he just seems to
think that he can win the vote without
the black people's support like Ronald
Reagan did he just seems to be
disrespectful and doesn't care that he's
ranking at 2% with black people what do
you think sir thank you very much
that's a good question Robert it's a
good question because it raises sort of
the non traditional aspects of Donald
Trump's campaign Trump has not done a
lot of the same speeches that any other
candidate in modern history has done you
know showing up at the N double ACP
annual meeting the Urban League just a
couple of weeks ago he didn't address
them you know I think this sort of
demonstrates that he is an atypical
candidate who doesn't always listen to
the same political advice or political
advisors that everybody else does which
is in one sense a part of his appeal to
his base is that he's not politics as
usual in the other sense that it is
there's a reason that people try to
appeal to more voters appeal to more
voters you win more votes Trump has has
yet to to really do that in this one
particular aspect and I think that's
just another example of him being a
different kind of candidate is it a tug
of war between teleprompter Donald Trump
and non teleprompter Donald Trump if it
is it is a tug of war that not that the
teleprompter Donald Trump is being
dragged across the field I mean he can't
teleprompter Donald Trump does not last
more than a few days right it is there
was a great story over the weekend the a
one left-hand story in the New York
Times on Sunday talking about Donald
Trump and his that's exactly that sort
of tug and pull and it was a great
little anecdote in the end where he said
you know just last week they sat down
with his advisers and he promised once
again that you know this time it was
really the end and he was he was going
to he was going to shape up and act like
a real candidate and stay on script and
then a few hours later he made the
second amendment comments about Hillary
Clinton so that sort of tells you how
long these sort of resets last it's sort
of compare compare one of Donald Trump's
promises to stay on teleprompter to the
Clinton campaigns promises to
reintroduce Hillary Clinton
you know one person who's been in the
spotlight for 30 years - OH - some for
80,000 one for Republicans - OH - semper
80,000 for Democrats - OH - semper eight
eight thousand - for Independence link
Bridgeport Connecticut independent line
hi there hi there good morning you know
thank you so much for c-span and
discussion points I wanted to posit
something I'm speaking as a black
independent voter from Connecticut been
here for about twenty years now and
there's a lot of discussion in so far is
why Donald Trump is trying to make this
aggressive play in Connecticut well
here's something that I think a lot of
people haven't considered the Trump
during throughout his campaign has been
making a lot of strident comments that
have appealed to white supremacist
voters throughout the country the
anti-defamation league has stated that
and and found that per capita
Connecticut has the highest percentage
of white supremacists and hate group
activity of any state in the United
States Trump is making a very calculated
and very intriguing ideal out of
essentially utilizing usurping white
supremacist voters who are very active
although they're sublimated on the
public purview and on the public village
but still extraordinarily active and
extraordinarily vocal in their opinions
to essentially get and you try to herald
and try to elicit their support at the
voting booths in in November and he's
betting that can give him a heightened
edge of a voter security in November the
voter security issue is one that keeps
me up at night this this notion that
Donald Trump has started talking about
the fact that we've got a rigged
election or if he doesn't win it's
because things are rigged that that
really worries me and worries me because
we are we have a president right now who
beautiful Americans believe truly
believe is an illegitimate President of
the United States based on you know
fictional information that they read on
the Internet
what if that number is 40 percent that
that worries me well what if what if 40
or 45 percent of Americans think an
election was stolen
remember Al Gore and John Kerry ran two
very close races with a with a president
who beat them and in both cases they
conceded and they conceded graciously
and they went about their business I
have a hard time thinking Donald Trump
will concede even if he loses by 20
points
that sort of that sort of way but the
polling that we've seen lately shows
that he's way down in a lot of these
states that there's a reason the Clinton
campaign is trying to move into Arizona
and Georgia and it's not just to get
Senate candidates to win its tried to
try to build her electoral vote capacity
I didn't know that Connecticut had had
so many groups like that but it's
surprising I'm from the west coast
myself and I was talking to a a Western
governor a couple of months ago and he
said something he joked he said
something like you know I'm from the
black helicopter capital of America
and you know these sort of these groups
exist you know all over the country
Kirkland Washington Republican line Lam
hello hello I recently just threw in an
old 20 year old videotape to watch to
see what was on it and I got 60 minutes
from from the 1996 election with Andy
Rooney interviewing Bob Dole and Bob
Dole never showed up for the interview
so Andy Rooney was just interviewing an
empty chair and I thought it was quite
interesting in the question that he
asked Bob Dole the question was quote
the public doesn't seem to be much
influenced by bad things politicians do
there have been so many politicians who
you know got caught stealing or did
something else wrong and were then
re-elected but it seems sometimes as if
though people just don't care about the
things you know white water or Jennifer
flowers or anything like that if any of
these charges are true about the
Clintons would that really matter to
voters
so I guess my question is
just get tired presidential election
after election where all these charges
are back and forth back and forth does
it really seem to matter them thank you
very much and and that's a really good
point they're like you know it we've
we've talked about how the 2016 election
is the post truth you know election and
everybody's just throwing out these
these you know charges about the media
and all this stuff well hey you know
history repeats and apparently 20 years
ago is exactly the same way and by the
way Andy Rooney interviewing an empty
chair isn't that the most Andy Rooney
thing ever
he was playing great he's my college
graduation speaker really at George
Washington but Chris in Alabama on
Twitter asks the same kind of question
saying Republicans worry about the
Clinton Foundation while Trump's
campaign managers or C twelve million
from the Russians or either of those
stories long-lasting in this scam day
should be I mean they these are they're
from there are serious stories here on
both sides one of the one of the
fascinating things about this about this
election is you know we're all so
obsessed with the daily story that we
miss these larger looks at what's going
on and and you know the media the media
the the evil media has done a great job
in in writing long form deep
investigative stories about Donald Trump
and about Hillary Clinton and and they
are on the front page of any news like
here's here's a good idea let's all
subscribe to newspapers again it is you
know they're the front page of Sunday
newspapers and they're and they're good
interesting stories and then somebody
says something crazy at 8:55 on a Monday
morning and about it's almost David I
saw I'll say I'll say something crazy in
a few minutes and it'll dominate the
news cycle for a day and then we miss
that really great story that took you
know six months to write there are there
that the foundation is a huge story that
we should be concerned about one of the
I mean the Clintons you know Hillary
Clinton in releasing her taxes over the
weekend you know showed that she'd made
X number of dollars I can't remember the
exact figure but X number of dollars
from paid speeches well who was she
giving these speeches to and I mean
that's all in you know that's mostly
public record and but we should be
looking at that do those people are
those people trying to gain influence in
future the people who donate to the
Clinton Foundation do they want
influence in a Clinton administration
that the Paul Manafort thing in in
Ukraine is shocking long profile in the
New York Times today so and and with
leaked documents found in you know in in
the capital and then these are big
important stories if we want to if the
media could get away from the five
second story and by the way when I say
that the media I mean cable news you
know newspapers look what's on the front
page New York Times that is big deep
impactful journalism but as we you know
if we can pause on that for a moment
point there's some big important stories
and there are a lot of journalists who
don't a lot of work and getting some
stuff out there Reid Wilson up the hill
their national correspondent joining us
for this discussion on campaign 2016
Dimitri from Oakland California
Democrats line go ahead good morning
are you familiar with Abraham Lincoln's
party system called the National Union
Party that was implemented after the
ending of the Civil War and he had
abolished the party system are you
familiar with this party but the Union
party was this everybody is on one
ballot and and so you don't have all of
these five of you gets rid of campaign
finance and so and so so this was the
party system was abolished he was no
longer a Republican he was he was known
as National Union Party so why don't you
think that since the Republicans are
behind Abraham Lincoln why don't you
think that they're not a union party
well I'm not sure that that's exactly
how it happened in 1864 when Lincoln was
running for reelection but the notion of
everybody being on the same ballot is
some
that actually exists in states like
California where the caller was from
California Washington State both have
top two primary elections so you put 18
candidates on the ballot and the top two
vote-getters regardless of party
advanced to a general election
mostly usually that means that one
Democrat and one Republican however in
California now that top two vote-getters
in their primary against Senator bar to
replace Senator Barbara Boxer two
Democrats
advance so only Democrats will be on the
ballot in November's election in
California in Washington State my home
state where our last caller was from
even though it is one of the most
liberal states in the country hasn't
elected a Republican governor since 1980
the - excuse me the two finalists on the
ballot in November for state treasurer
will both be Republicans so they're you
know Washington State gets a Republican
treasurer because they finished in the
top two in the primary Republican line
Corning New York mark good morning good
morning sir how you doing today good all
right how are you mark very well thank
you
I just have a comment that I would like
to make very quickly being from upstate
New York
we saw what what Hillary's policies do
for upstate New York and the people up
here where they've forgotten people and
and all I got to say is is that if you
want to shut their and you want to you
want to vote for for Hillary go right
ahead and she represents cheating lies
and theft now if you back to work again
roll up your sleeves and vote for Donald
Trump thank you so much for having me on
c-span so Marc brings up another good
example of important journalism and the
way that sort of the media is covering
this campaign I think it was was it last
weekend or early last week there was a
good story in The New York Times about
Hillary Clinton's record in upstate New
York as is as a senator from the state
of New York she promised X number of
jobs I won't say 200,000 that's a little
bigger okay okay so she promised 200,000
jobs to upstate New York and those jobs
never showed up that's a good story
and and hey it's part of her record
upstate New York has has been impacted
by we we think of New York as such a
liberal state but upstate especially in
western New York when you know the the
factory and Union jobs that were that
were the build jobs that were there once
are no longer there
thanks in part to NAFTA and CAFTA and
these trade deals that have shipped a
lot of that overseas you know so it is
it is a small Republican outpost in a
larger Democratic state but couldn't
promise to deliver jobs there and the
jobs never showed up so there you go
another example of good journalism and
people paying attention to and and more
than just the media snowfall because you
bring it up when you hear Donald Trump
then take swipes against the media's
particularly to his campaign what
crosses your mind that that he is
entirely running a campaign about
himself if he in in in this in this day
and age it is so much easier to run a
campaign by attacking the other
candidate by making the other candidate
appear unpalatable Donald Trump's not
doing that we're hearing a lot Hillary
Clinton is running all if you've watched
any of the election coverage Clinton's
running to ads she's running a positive
economic you know I'm gonna bring back a
million jobs ads and then the other edge
he's running is Donald Trump on
Letterman as he sits there and Letterman
looks at his you know sure his trumpet
was a shirt and tie line he's as where
as It's Made Bangladesh China as Trump
sits there looking awkward so there's a
negative ad Trump has a lot of
opportunity to talk about Hillary
Clinton and the things she has done
wrong whether it's having a private
email server the foundation of the
questions that raises her relationship
with with with James Comey at the FBI
who she said he was you know he
essentially absolved her and he didn't
at all there's a lot to talk about about
Hillary Clinton even the upstate New
York jobs Donald Trump doesn't do that
he doesn't do that because he feels like
he's being treated unfairly unfair is
being sort of the cornerstone word of
his campaign one wonders
for somebody who is who's that wealthy
how much does it matter if something is
unfair next up is Julian Vienna Virginia
independent line hi there
good morning the reason I'm calling is
that I've noticed that all morning long
you fellas have talked about only two
candidates as if they were the only two
people who are going to appear on the
ballot in November there are other
candidates who have serious political
experience and absolutely serious policy
positions established and published
which the media just does not talk about
and an example of how that affects the
binary way people think the gentleman
who called in from New York a minute ago
said that well and he didn't like mrs.
Clinton so therefore he was going to
vote for Trump as if Trump was the only
other alternative the question I have is
and I could probably answer the question
myself is why is he not thinking about
the possibility of misters Johnson and
weld and the answer to that is that you
folks in the media don't focus any
attention on those kind of as I said
earlier serious politicians with solid
political experience that you